let's make way for Ray Ratto Bay Area
long time sports columnist and here to
separate fact from fiction with the Tom
Brady 49ers rumors do you believe the
rumors ring I believe that the 49ers
would kick the tires I believe that's
where it ends where it ends yeah I said
look I think they asked about a lot of
things I mean they got Jimmy Garoppolo
because they asked about Tom Brady three
years ago yeah you know and that was
just a joke
but I think Kyle Shanahan the general
manager investigates a lot of things
that never really come to fruition and
this is one where I think the general
manager on his left shoulder is telling
him well go ahead and ask about it but
don't get to it don't get your hopes up
and the coach on his right shoulder
saying are you crazy I just don't know
that there's enough of a verifiable
upside for the 49ers to do the let's get
Brady and get rid of Garoppolo thing it
doesn't make it doesn't make sense to me
and I not sure that it makes sense to
Shanahan
yeah I was wondering about this from the
Niners perspective is you're gonna
basically say to somebody 15 years
younger than Brady that we're gonna cut
you to make way for Brady to come in
then he's got to get adjusted to Kyle
Shanahan system here I know Brady wants
to go where he can win and if you said
he could walk into the Niners lineup
right now it's probably the best place
for him to try to win a championship I'm
guessing but I just don't know the risk
and the reward with that of betting on
the next two years with Tom Brady or the
next 7 to 10 years which Jimmy grop will
have do you think that there will be
close to the ceiling with Garoppolo
would be probably the one question I
would want to know if the Niners feel
that way I don't know what the Niners
feel about him I mean they say all the
right things which of course means
they're probably lying but I think they
know that he is a better than league
average quarterback he's coming off a
year in which he basically put up
Brady's numbers and the real question is
not about him
about whether the struggles that Brady
had down the stretch are more indicative
of the weapons around him or of a
quarterback who's starting to see the
the event horizon and I think that's the
problem it just they kind of know what
they have in Garoppolo and what they
haven't Garoppolo is one of the many
quarterbacks who isn't Patrick mahomes I
mean they had that game won and what
happened was Pat mahomes did what Pat
mahomes does and that's how they lost
the Super Bowl it wasn't the Jimmy
Garoppolo threw up on himself it's that
the Chiefs do the thing that the Chiefs
did about four or five other times that
year which is fall behind then score a
million points in 40 seconds and win and
I think if if you want to say that this
is Jimmy Garoppolo spalled
you're probably guilty of thinking the
quarterbacks are the only positions that
matter in football and they're not so I
mean to me if he was if he was up below
if he was Andy Dalton yeah I think
they'd think about it if he was you know
a lot of quarterbacks I think they think
about it but I think they view him as a
good quarterback with the odd flaw or
two like most quarterbacks
I mean he's not drew brees he's not
Patrick mahomes you know he's not Lamar
Jackson but he's in that he's in the
rest of that field and I think it
becomes now a risk reward do you want to
pay twice as much money for a guy who's
15 years older and who's coming off a
year in which he started to look old for
one reason or another and I just think
that Kyle Shanahan is too conservative a
thinker to make that kind of deal and I
may know it if Bill Belichick wants to
make that kind of deal you know where he
gets the 28 year old and the Patriots
give up the 43 year old I don't think it
Bill Belichick knows something and I'm
gonna try to avoid being the guy who
thinks just the opposite I am yeah I I
think the what kind of went under the
radar is that nine or that vaunted
defense that folded in the fourth
quarter
like I can blame Garoppolo for not
closing out and had a couple throws one
got knocked down but I think I think
defense is what lost that Super Bowl in
my opinion yeah well and I thought I
think the Chiefs offense which you know
basically crushes and eats Souls as a
hobby did that I mean they I mean
they've done they if it wasn't for the
fact that they had done it before to
Tennessee and I watched them doing in
eight minutes against a an Oakland
defense which isn't very good I mean I
would say yeah the 49ers letdown but one
of the things that made the Chiefs great
was it they they wear you down they did
they're they're standing on your chest
the whole time and urging you to breathe
and eventually you stopped me just you
know I'm tired get off my chest and
that's when they beat you so I think
this was more a matter of Kansas City
winning than the 49er defense losing
because I think Patrick mahomes was that
good this year that he could make even
great defenses cry and I mean the 49ers
are not going to do anything material to
their defense this year I think they'll
try to upgrade their secondary a bit and
they'll throw a bunch of money at Arik
Armstead or they'll give that money to
Tom Brady and then have to look with no
quarterback at a future in two years
that may have them have no quarterback
for a while because quarterbacks are not
you know enough with every aisle at
Costco anymore you've got to you've got
to find a guy you love and you've got to
make sure he doesn't get hurt and you've
got to make sure you spend money to
protect him and give him weapons I mean
it's not easy to fix
a quarterback vacuum as many of the
teams this this this winter who have
quarterback vacuums you're finding you
know I mean people are tossing out you
know Philip Rivers at 39 as a reasonable
alternative I mean it is you know I mean
look Tom Brady's resume is I mean it's
painted gold and it stacks to the
ceiling but you're not getting the
resume you're getting what's left and
guessing what's left is mostly art and
you know wetting your finger and you
know waiting for the wind
whereas Garoppolo I mean I my guess is
Kyle Shanahan looks grapple and says
there are things we can fix on him and
they're not big fixes so I think this
can be this can be easily done I just
think the risk reward is out of whack
for this deal before I let you go I
wanted to have one Golden State question
we're talking to Ray Ratto a longtime
sports columnist in the Bay Area what is
the bigger picture game plan for the
Warriors when everybody's healthy you
got a high draft pick what what is next
you're going to be like well next year
is not going to be this year because
this year is the answer to every
question everybody has ever asked what
if the best college team played a team
in the pros cuz it's hard on the eyes
even beating Denver last night you just
you know just go why am i watching this
this is hideous but I think the next
year's big picture sort of starts with
what kind of vibe they get watching
Stephon Curry play with Andrew Wiggins
and even an injured draymond Green to
get an idea if they can pick up all the
nuances and subtleties that they built
up over five years while really seven
years and go forward or whether they
think they need to move Wiggins to load
up on more draft picks if they decide
they want Wiggins then then they don't
have to do anything with their pick and
they can basically take anybody that
they want I just don't know that this is
a draft in which immediate help is going
to result but having the worst record
and maybe even winning the lottery
allows them the luxury of thinking well
maybe we can package this and Wiggins
and get something we really like on the
market so I think the the long-term
thing is they're going to be okay but
how are they going to be okay I don't
think they believe that that Curry's
injury is you know career damaging I
don't think they think that Thompson's
is career damaging I think they've been
ultra conservative in in medical
decision since the Durant thing so
that's why they view you know Korea as
not being a guy they need to rush back
but I think they do want to watch him
play with Wiggins to get an idea of what
the preferred path for the offseason is
because the preferred
for the offseason is going to tell you
how they tackle next year if everything
goes great and Wiggins and curry fit
like a glove together I mean they're you
know fifty to fifty four wins if it
doesn't and they've got to go a
different way it might be a bit more of
a scrape to get in
I just dawned on me and and this
probably isn't a fair question to be
asking but it's not just a girl to
happen absolutely if if it would have
been klay Thompson her Steph Curry who
suffered that injury in the leading and
into the postseason instead of Kevin
Durant
would they have rushed them but they
knew Kevin Durant was probably leaving
or at least had a pretty good indication
I I don't know if if that factored in in
getting him back to playing if it would
have been Steph Curry who suffered that
injury would they have expedited his
return I think they probably would have
handled it exactly the same way okay I
think what happened to Kevin Durant was
terrible luck because there's no real
way I mean as much as these guys know
about medicine about how you know how a
players going to come back from an
injury I mean curry could come back with
this you know bit of nerve damage in his
hand and suddenly become a terrible
shooter I mean I don't think that's the
way to bet and I don't think they rushed
Durant back I mean if they really felt
like they needed to rush him back he'd
have been back a week earlier I mean I
you know I think this was a combination
of educated choices from Durant's people
from the Warriors medical people and
from the Warriors themselves I don't
think they they thought that there was
any kind of appreciable risk and
rehearsing
I mean I realized that you know this
disappoints conspiracy freaks everywhere
but you know I think they should
probably spend more time updating their
job resumes the know I think I think
they got really bad luck and and Durant
got the worst luck of all and I don't
think they would have handled him any
differently I don't think they would
have handled curry or Thompson any
differently than they than they did
Durant except for the fact that they're
different injuries so to me in
I think what happened to the Warriors
you know I mean they were playing a very
difficult team in Toronto might have won
anyway but Durant was not you know
medical malfeasance it was terrible luck
and you know listen and I mean if they
had forced her aunt to play that would
be a different argument but Durant you
know who could you know look for an
alibi anyway he wanted has always said
no no I got no problem with what they
did we signed off on everything - I mean
he's back there play and when he doesn't
really need to so I think they just you
know bad luck basically bit them on the
head for the first time in half a decade
great to talk to you again ray hope
you're well thanks for joining us as
always I always enjoy being on meathead
Wednesday thank you that's ray Ratto
long time Bay Area sports writer